maybe the Skywalker term is now a name
for a force user just in general if Luke
Skywalker can project his force ghost to
another planet
why can't force ghosts be projected
through time it's a bunch of
specifically of rey and she this is
rogue theory today we're talking about
brains there be melted because of Raisa
Skywalker not just because the trailer
came out and I'm so pumped about it but
what you guys know we've been talking
about it non-stop but also there's like
news about rise of Skywalker that is
crazy crazy crazy we can get into it on
today's episode we have Eric Bostrom of
course Sam basher guys okay we have to
predict what crazy stuff and I'm like
pretty pumped there's crazy stuff on so
it's gonna happen and Watchmen cuz
Watchmen was really crazy we could talk
about that later but who cares the last
trailer rises Skywalker came out this
week you can see Eric did a really great
breakdown of it already there's so much
like that they're also hiding from us
even though they showed us a lot of new
stuff so I've been really excited to
tell you guys about this because Kevin
Smith a few months ago said something
that blew my mind about his mind being
blown and now I can't wait to talk to
you guys about it any you guys about it
alright so he visited the set of Raisa
Skywalker and he was gonna you know just
take a tour of all the different
locations and this is big guys listen to
this okay so there was I guess a room
that was like oh by the way in that room
is the final shot of the movie to set
that's what's in there and the crew
member that pointed out that said but if
you look it'll blow your mind and now I
feel like that didn't like like land as
high okay so he didn't look but here's
here's the biggest like like
justification of why I'm freaking out
about it cuz he asked his old friend JJ
Abrams he said I mean like I can look in
that ruined JJ's like no if you look in
that room it'll ruin the entire movie
for you
[Applause]
either the whole movie would be spoiled
for him if he saw what was in that room
it was mind-blowing
it's a Harrison Ford to blow your mind
guys blow our minds how will the last
set the last scene the last location of
rise of Skywalker
melt melt our minds I want to hear some
theories okay
just if you walked into a set and you
were like now my mind's blown it's a
bunch of clones right because that
exists and it's a bunch of Rey and she's
just hanging on hooks it's like if you
cuz if they had walked into that said
then he'd be like oh my god this whole
thing is just a bunch of clones of Rey
which would be Rey clone confirmed yes
would be huge okay so whose clones are
they they're Palpatine's class you know
like army clone army so he own suppose
it's not his DNA he's a clone owner
created them and but he doesn't want
obviously anybody to find out about it
so he keeps them in his clone closet
closet so their closet yet but yeah
great so they I'm loving it because
Palpatine I mean the idea of a clone
army has exist
yes yeah and it was based on kind of
like a great assassin busy they're like
what if somebody who's really good at
killing we make a bunch of clones of
them instead it's like wait wait shut up
do it a Jedi yeah exactement of a Jedi
also maybe raise already a clone right
that's right well that would basically
I'll throw out there from extended
universe crap that there is a clone of
Luke Skywalker and he has the best name
for a cat Luke Skywalker Luke Walker
pretty close Luke Skywalker there's
literally one more you but use the legit
part of it it's because of his hand
recovered very quickly
starfish principle clones of also of
Luke for your idea but also maybe like a
luke altered clone who's like kind of
the next generation of t800 or something
is ray maybe or whoever the host I mean
if you're doing it I don't know what if
they're doing it the traditional way
where it has to be birth a man and a
woman right like there's still a host
woman who has like her DNA could just
make it female and be you know raised
mom there you go kind of mom as a
surrogate it like verifies like when
riot kylo Ren kinda like throws away
that your parents aren't important is
like oh yeah because they just like
donated their DNA clone warriors that's
pretty cool but so partial clone factory
partial sperm donation centers it's a
big galaxy there's a lot of options well
my own mind is the location how do you
guys feel about this idea yeah if I'm
blind a bunch of young Mark Hamill's on
meat hooks hanging from the ceiling I
have to give you one Rogi and then I'll
clone it for a sec
so I'm super into because it confirms
rates of clone it wouldn't blow our
minds and it would also tie in the
prequels which i think is fun yeah
exactly
cool Sam okay here you go I think about
this and this is what's something this
is what people have wanted since we
heard we were getting new Star Wars
movies once Disney bought them how about
by the end of this movie they've been
talking about a while that for a while
that Sith bad boys bad boys bad girls
but you don't want him anymore
what you're gonna do get rid of them but
at the same time we're learning that the
Jedi aren't all that they're not up to
snuff that's what there is suddenly
learning that yes and they're really
trying to hammer at home as hard as they
can even Yoda showed up in the last
movie was like you didn't even read the
books did you you're not a real nerd get
out of here so basically we're learning
that while the joy the ones we've been
trying to like follow and look up to
there might be a better way of teaching
people the force because we know in the
last show there are just people that our
force users out there and the galaxy
that need to be trained in some way so
by the end of this movie I feel like a
brain melting scene would be seeing some
sort of academy or temple where they're
teaching the force but they're not
teaching sis or Jedi this is a I think
I'm pretty sure you've done a theory
like this there's been many theories
like that out there that the Skywalker
name limit a boy Skywalker term is now a
name for a force user just in general
but so you gettin just Skywalker force
users and you're getting in the sense
that and also we know that these like
really chill trilogies are cyclical so
with that it could be in a larger cycle
the return of an Academy similar to the
Knights of the Old Republic we are
having teachers who were training the
next generation way better than Luke
Skywalker apparently he's a bad teacher
from nothing ready to look to Medina old
man to barely talk and now there's a yes
you saw him he had a chance with those
kids and then he tried to murder one of
them in their sleep
he was holding a warm you know what like
I it is troublesome because there's even
fewer force users going forward but
maybe with kylo and Rick together they
do establish the end of last Jedi that
their new force users born everyday true
but teachers who could help them
understand that right back in on your
idea that all the existing teachers are
been bad
basically then a cycle maybe there is a
whole new way to they're just sitting up
a credential system where you can
actually become at the school is to
become a teacher
just the force-sensitive users that that
kind of could go in any direction
there's a bunch of those established I
definitely feel like if somebody were to
just vote yeah Maz Kanata kind of talks
about the force in a way that kind of is
ignores the history of the Jedi and I
think she's an example of somebody that
could potentially help teach it she it
seems is probably for sensitive herself
to mm-hmm and by the end of it you
getting your x-men or Harry Potter I ask
school where people are going to learn
how to use the force and they go out and
they bring peace to the galaxy or they
don't and we find out in the next
trilogy where they mess up again but I
think and by the end of this we're gonna
see a unification of the force users and
that mirrors history cuz like every 30
years we find out that the past
generations curriculum and schools were
evil in some way it requires them to be
burned down and started a new one that
is now the heroic leader of the new age
so okay so I'm gonna assign a rogue II
to this idea because even though I think
that it is very good I really love the
idea of the balance of the force I also
think it's there's one issue going on
what stars right now where a recent film
kind of like felt like it shifted the
trajectory a little bit of the saga I it
had this theme very heavily in there of
you know Jedi aren't so good I mean
Benicio Del Toro's character has am all
about it but he's afraid to call the
last Jedi out by me they shifted kind of
what they don't like the saga had been
about so now I feel like JJ's got a job
to do which is kind of like okay I need
to make this just makes sense for nine
movies this is one of the few things
that I think could actually unify all
the themes I'll even throw out there
that it works for rogue one right rogue
one showed a very dangerous guerrilla
warfare style of like rebellion that is
kind of calling out like should is
that's not really okay either so I'm
giving you that rogue II for that I
can't give you two because I think it's
too likely to happen
the rules here just put some people on
meat hooks and you'll be too many points
Philip I think you're exactly right that
that is where the last Jedi or the rise
of Skywalker is heading where JJ has
this gargantuan task of having to tie in
all these other films and that brings me
to what my theory is
I think the one of the biggest mysteries
from the prequels but one that I think
people want to redress is the origin of
Anakin Skywalker he was Shmi said that
there was no father implying this like
weird Immaculate Conception yeah that's
what she said had a difference Watto I
do think if you think what kind of set
would blow someone's my way back to
Tatooine been seen that'd be cool like
where's me raised Anakin a child maybe
bringing back that actress showing
Anakin's child at bedroom with like his
Threepio that he was building a child
what you know we got a return to exactly
what he just said you mean in the past
in the past you know time chairs that's
one way we could be seen a version of
time travel we're definitely seen time
travel because like we can if if Luke
Skywalker can project his force ghost to
another planet why can't force ghosts be
projected through time this was Luke
Skywalker sitting there in the last Jedi
on that rock for the entire several
hours projecting the force ghost or was
he just in that moment projecting his
force ghost a couple years yeah to
confront kylo now do I think ray and/or
kylo force projecting their force ghosts
back to the past would that be the final
shot
I don't know that'd be a weird note to
end this entire song on so if it's not
that I I think it's some kind of
flashback showing that moment ending
with like a young Anakin building three
people because I think based off of this
trailer three pios sacrifice whether
he's interfacing with some new ship or
if they're scanning his memories which
were wiped
- Revenge of the Sith I think ending
with that moment of three POS light
flickering on in the first time in
Anakin childhood bedroom would be a
really beautiful place and potentially a
mind lighting place a new scene we
haven't seen where it's young Jake Lloyd
through CGI it's like in bed or just to
the side and and Threepio goes and he
tucks him in and he's like good night
master Anakin you will kill millions
just sits at his bedside with his lights
on and robots aren't allowed to sleep
okay beautiful we can't find unlikely of
course that's terrifying I do really
like the idea though of time travel I
even like it through the forest coasting
because it does two things one time
travel is the one thing that's missing
from they've literally done everything
else just throw in time forever why not
yeah I and also JJ Abrams have done time
travel before but to also on a day James
showed that he wasn't running it by the
time the idea that in death time is no
longer important you're kind of stuck in
time I could totally see this idea that
maybe every Force Coast we've seen from
Yoda way back when to you know recently
uh Luke you could imagine these are all
happening to them concurrently they're
just coasting anywhere in time that it's
needed and so maybe one of these times
is back then but the thing that here
you've already earned a rope but Derek
the thing that this needs for me to give
you a second one is I need to understand
what new information we learn about
Anakin's conception maybe we learned
that I think just revealing someone that
we know is Anakin's father I don't want
to say that Palpatine is revealed to be
and it gets why I think that'd be too
much of a downer to end the whole thing
this weird senator from Naboo found some
time to get over to or or that city a su
existed
wouldn't be the senator because
Palpatine the senator from Naboo was a
facade it was really Sidious existed
long before he decided politics would be
the way to his fame and fortune
so not Palpatine yeah okay I'm down with
with it being somebody that we know
though and you're saying Palpatine's too
much of a downer right give you a crazy
spin then it who would be an upper
exciting interesting huh
raise his dad what I mean well I don't
know much about how that works but but I
assume two people love each other baby
happens but I actually hurts me no I
think in a in a non-sexual way like if
we went it's a little bit emerging
marinus theory a little bit too but like
from what we understand your hand you
get a baby which I would have many
babies of my own right now but no but
you know what I mean where it's like
maybe there was like some essence or
something that was used to make Anakin
and the only reason I know this is like
stupid ridiculous the only reason that's
interesting to me is because we've been
worrying this whole time about who or
Rey's parents and it's like oh she's
just a little bit the ending of one of
the original South Park episodes of
trying to figure out who Cartman's dad
is and it turns out to be his mom mom
yeah I mean if it's it feels like
predestination right like I'm my own
grandfather or yeah so she it does make
it full circle and cyclical do you get
the I'll save it and if anybody needs it
and you can break the glass so she
becomes the parent of space Hitler no
but remember at the end he says my bad
and the like a happy young force ghost
even though everybody else doesn't get
to do that yeah it makes sense yeah it
works out actually I really like all
these they did a good job going rogue
road this week who do you guys like the
most your own theories yeah I mean where
there's like young because it like it's
a weird jab fans it's like look all your
favorite characters can live on forever
as clones and they just burn it down
it's like breaking the fourth wall with
the toy store or something
and then they burn it down and then they
melt little kids Minds right this is how
your toys get made bringing melted it's
ballsy guys we're gonna get our
predictions per season one of watchmen
after this quick break to talk about a
cool thing that we're doing the rock
stars hey everyone Eric here we're at
new rock stars are super excited for the
rise of Skywalker to come out like you
know we're just gonna buzzing around our
office making that hour - screaming town
yeah that's us one project we've always
want to do is a breakdown of each of the
classic Star Wars films the original
trilogy plus the prequels to join the
ones that we've done for the more recent
films are please just really other
things we want to make for you guys each
of those breakdowns takes like two to
three times longer than the other videos
we make so it break down to the original
Star Wars Empire Strikes Back return the
Jedi Phantom Menace attack of the clones
and Revenge of the Sith are something
you would like to see new rock stars
tackle please consider becoming a patron
of new rock stars Digital Studios we are
trying to expand our operation here to
do even more stuff and with your help we
can do it plus patrons will receive
perks of early access to certain videos
and bonus exclusive classic film
breakdowns each month check out the
details for yourself by clicking the
link in the description below or by
going to patreon.com slash new rockstars
guys first episode of HBO's Watchmen
series came out last week and we loved
it in that we love to be very confused
things mostly we can't stop talking
about it
so based on the first episode we're
gonna make some predictions on what's
gonna happen this season the winner of
this prediction round gets to replace
marinas picture hosts marina wins again
but I have a feeling she's not going to
know so you why in a sec as whoever is
the most accurate so she's up there
because of her out Camino video so this
gets graded in the future when we've
seen the first season of Watchmen the
reason why marina might not do so well
in this is because she has not read the
Watchmen comic and I don't know how
anybody's following even just this
episode without having read it it's very
but I really like this perspective
because I feel like this is more than
half of the people that tuned in to this
episode also do not read the comic so
they're equally as confused and very I
represent a significantly a
statistically significant percentage
exact population I can't wait to hear
what your presence will be
it will sound like I don't know what I'm
talking all right guys
first off I will start with Eric I want
to know what beats plan is is it meat
bait bait a dream fate Jeremy Irons we
think we think but I believe it yeah
that is it what is what his what's his
plan for season one what's he know why
is he getting basally okay so dude he's
got some weird stuff going on he's got
this remote mansion he lives in there
was a newspaper headline that said he
was declared dead that's why some people
are saying oh maybe Jeremy Irons didn't
play I think he is I just think this guy
is a master of cover-ups I think he just
doesn't want people to think he's alive
my theory is that he is going to be a
similar figure to Ford in West world
Ford a lot of people thought he was dead
or don't think he's dead now I don't
know if he is he's become this architect
figure he has these like look like
either clones or robots or whatever
people who don't know they're like Janet
they're like horseshoe serving - I think
there's something wrong with that cake
maybe it's made of wax or something
that's why he's like okay they can't
taste it they they're just trying to
please him I think he's built like a
household of servants filled with like
either robots or androids or clones of
some kind and he is the master watch
maker he's putting on a play called the
watchmakers son yeah I think his plan is
to use these clones to do his bidding
and I think really his bidding is he's
trying to clone dr. Manhattan he's
trying should simply engineering a new
dr. Manhattan so dr. Manhattan would be
the watch maker would be the watchmakers
because I think in the he'd be the
watchmaker son the original comics his
father was a watchmaker so the play his
narrative is the watchmaker son how do
you grade that based on you know how you
know everything I know sounds realistic
to me I I agree you go all right
say what you think all right so from the
begin the past we go further past we go
further back than the comic even goes
and they show us the massacre in Tulsa
yeah and and we're focusing on one child
in particular who is a character in the
present day and who has lived
very he's lived for far too long so
there has to be some tie to dr.
Manhattan or maybe Ozymandias in some
way my guess since they are telling an
arat of that has to do with like they're
mentioning Watchmen the original comic
has to do with time a lot I think we're
gonna get time travel I think it's gonna
go where Ozymandias his plan set in
motion how the world behaves today and I
think and also go on HBO's website they
have all these documents that are like
the interstitials from the comic that
like fill in the gaps of what happened
between the comic and now and then
explain how he can hide I really
appreciate it but my my thing is that
his whole thing is trying to create a
world that has peace and it's his
version of it so a way to do that is
maybe he's using the tachyons that he's
used to block out what dr. Manhattan and
so we can't basically see what
Ozymandias plan is before before you go
to further explain what happens in the
comic around this idea basically at the
end of the last comic photos for The
Watchmen for the comic yep Ozymandias
makes a big psychic squid and he
teleports it in the middle of New York
City and it kills a bunch of people and
basically ends the class that's why
there were who's that baby squids yeah I
was like what the f is the whole point
is that for some reason a dimensional
barrier that's a narrative open and this
came out right it's mentioned that yeah
and now we don't have any more threats
on earth there's we don't have why would
we fight each other when there's gonna
spew squid right yeah so pretty solid oh
yeah and it worked enough it worked
enough the tease at the end is that
maybe something will come out and it
will be out of that this did not this
was manufactured and there's also teases
that throughout this first episode and
because of the presence of the tachyons
during the squid event yeah
dr. Manhattan our Superman was not able
to do anything about it he couldn't see
what was happening so Ozymandias having
access to all this sci-fi gobbledygook
is able to possibly go back in time and
rewrite history in some way I think
because they're focusing so hard on the
American hero story that we're gonna get
a lot a lot of info about the first
superheroes the first vigilantes I think
he's going to go back and alter it in
some way I know you
earn this because time-travel happen in
a big pan okay so he's he's gonna alter
time he has to hide it from dr.
Manhattan who was not able to stop him
on assignment so you can't stop him
again but but you got to go for what is
he trying to change about time I think
he has a grander vision like he's
writing his own play now like he's
creating his own life forms that are
helping him out I think he has a grander
vision of what society could be and I
think he has an idea of how to achieve
peace in a just a totally messed up way
and by going back in time I think he
died squids would show up earlier so
that fears instilled earlier so there we
go squid God yeah yeah I like most of
that all right
marina what's Ozymandias his real plan
oh well I sure know what it is and and
you definitely know which character
we're talking don't say his name they
don't but Jeremy Irons isn't it yes and
this is just like just you know pretend
that you are sitting down to watch
Watchmen for the first time and you did
see the Watchmen movie but it was so
long ago and you only saw it once so and
it turns out doesn't help you either
because it is not knowing that okay well
then great so just imagine that you
watch this hour of TV and you don't know
any of that information and then you see
squids falling on this guy and a bunch
of people doing a bunch of things don't
make sense and then Jeremy Irons comes
in and he's rich and he has servants and
he says you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna write a play you know what I think
I believe him I think he's gonna write a
very good play and it's gonna be a very
good musical as well and those two
actors are gonna go on to be stars and
he's essentially he's an old white
lin-manuel Miranda he's going to
Broadway and he's just gonna have a nice
career that's my take you know what
logically though it exactly is you just
watch that one episode
musical before watchmen happened somehow
you only watch that episode it makes a
hundred percents and marina got a
nonsensical Rogge very good guys next
question alright Judd so Don Johnson's
character might mister Miami Vice what
is his secret it feels like there's a
secret reason why he ended up the way
you did so what is his secret that we
don't know yet I think he is the leader
of the seventh Cavalry
what is the terrorist group the
terrorist organization that has taken
their inspiration from Rorschach they
wear the masks they quote him but they
have fused it with their white
supremacist agenda I think he's a leader
that organization I think he's a racist
and I think he was kind of playing both
sides whole city in the seventh what's
your you don't have to have any bullet
to your pseudo evidence well he was he
was murdered and there was a scene at
the beginning of the episode this old
silent film with a with bass Reeves
and he he lassos and he gets the the
crooked Sheriff like this isn't the
sheriff has been stealing the cattle the
white hat they did the reverse of the
old Western imagery the black hat
captured the white hat and it's like the
young Bill Reeves watch that he's like
yeah yeah listen to the law yeah and
then at the end of the episode he does
the same thing he he Lynch is the
crooked Sheriff clearly he's like
Johnson's doing weird stuff throughout
this episode he like covers up the
evidence he uses the owl ship to burn
this the escaping seven cavalry people
he he doesn't summon lady or sister
knight to do it like he calls her late
and he's kind of mad that she got one of
the guys ahead of time to interrogate
which led to that cattle farm like he's
clearly not happy with this being
investigated properly Rogi first of all
for his theory
delicious evidence also throw in there
that that picture right that they show
the picture you boy that's something I
don't know what it is he's a little
racist kid and it's really funny about
it is just just a picture of a little
maybe blond boy in black and white and
it feels like something about pop
culture status like that little boy's a
racist they had color and he chose not
to use I think you're on on a great
track here Jud secret Jed secret I I'd
go with that I I think he has ties to
the seventh Cavalry but little twist in
the fur coming up on Watchmen we learned
that there are business owners who are
coming into Tulsa and they're saying
that the future of the world starts here
so I'm gonna guess that he has not only
ties to the seventh Cavalry I think he
knows about Ozymandias I think he has
ties what he wants to bring to play
there in this new world but also I think
he has ties to what it means for the
future of law enforcement and vigilantes
and that could have ties to big business
and there's a lot of political drama
that's going behind on behind the scenes
in this world we hear talk of the Blue
Wave after Nixon left office and with
Robert Redford but in a in a more
general sense I think that Judd was is
responsible for possibly a newer threat
coming in that is not just the seventh
Cavalry and I think it has ties to the
new presidency and Ozymandias and in all
the way to the top in a more specific
sense I love that thank you I don't have
anything else after that his secret is
is that he's got ties he's got ties so
you kind of did The Price is Right move
of takes Erik's theory at one cent not
only Maryland but not
yeah that's again Oh what's what's Tom
Johnson secret Don Johnson that's pretty
short and sweet it's simple
is that he's a good guy now but he
didn't used to be because he grew up
that old based on that old picture this
is how you know well whatever it's
something about me it's like I saw that
old picture of him and an old white dude
and I was like no old white men they
teach you how to be racist golfer for
sure and he so he used to be he has
committed like bad crimes in the past
but he and but it's like when he was
anonymously in whatever that group is
called and he changed his ways he's a
good cop now like genuinely he's in like
he's on the side of goodness or whatever
but he never paid for those crimes so
him get doing or whatever happens to him
at the end is his payment for those
crimes that nobody knows about
I actually really like yes cuz the
lesson in the movies the justice always
prevails so eventually economy yeah I
will assume that that's true having seen
one episode yes I wasn't leaving a full
rogge but then you kind of like saw your
something put there because I it was
it's really really great but then it
sounds like you're not 100% sure about
your up thing or what do you think he
said that based on in this world you
said justice always prevails and having
seen one episode I don't know that
that's true yet but I believe you so it
makes me more right gotcha all right I
regret giving you only a quarter I'm
taking it back
marina I'm actually most on board
marinas too but I think we might lose
her here what's going on with dr.
Manhattan also did you notice he was in
the episode marina no yes
so dr. Manhattan we know will be part of
the show we saw him on Mars demolishing
his castle which he notice looks very
similar to the castle that Veit Jimmy
lives in the English countryside
wherever he is it has the same
architectural shape and design like I do
in a practice run yeah there's something
with that I don't know if he's doing a
practice run and that's like his
practice I think that is dr. Manhattan
on Mars I don't think Veit has a
capability to travel to another planet
yet yeah but I think the dr. Manhattan
is going to come back at some what we've
seen you know in upcoming weeks and with
the trailer he's gonna be there
I think either he is going to have to
confront this proto dr. Manhattan kind
of like Superman confronting Lex
Luthor's proto of Superman that he's
built you know bizarro you know or what
we're going to see is dr. Manhattan has
been involved with everything we've seen
in this fictional watchman timeline from
the beginning I might be looking into it
but in the opening scene of when the
young will Reeves gets the baby and he
looks at the this crash that he was in
there's this weird blue lens flare that
seems like it's coming from the
headlights but the way this lens flare
is it's not just like a JJ Abrams lens
flare this is like it seems specific and
the way that Don Johnson was when he was
blinded by this bluish light Regina King
was blinded by a bluish light I think
like dr. Manhattan may be helping will
Reiser string up this body that he's
like guiding his old like this hold
friend I believe that will Reeves has
actually hooded justice by the way but I
believe he's guiding his former
Minutemen and he's now involved in like
rearranging all the historical events
because he's so apathetic he's removed
from space and time he can see the past
present future all at the same time he's
just like trying to rearrange events so
that they're like they go according to
this specific plan which involves like
killing Don Johnson's characters kind of
like another doctor dr. strange yeah
he's all the options except he has no
shame about being like you know what I'm
just gonna change everything
and then it will end with just like all
this reality collapsing in on itself and
just becoming the reality that we know
it to be that this is all just like some
cautionary tale that's inside dr.
Manhattan's vision of like how things
could go if like history played out
differently and if superheroes existed
why I mean it doesn't totally make sense
by the end of the series that was a
direct attack on States so like say can
you beat that
okay so at the end of the Watchmen comic
and the movie Oh dr. Mann so he at the
end is like you know when I was a man
dias I don't care anymore
you know like that classic Futurama mean
we're Professor flies away off the
planet he doesn't live there anymore
dr. Manhattan does that for the whole
universe he says you know what I'm done
I'm done with his BS I'm leaving you
guys figure out all I'll say is you
think this is gonna work and this is not
and then he says produces and he leaves
yeah what if he we're not actually
looking at the Watchmen universe that's
from the comic or from the movie in this
show what if they're taking what if he
actually did leave the universe and the
reason why he's hanging out on Mars is
because he's now observing a new earth
so once he comes down to earth because
we know he will but it's a nice suit he
orders a salad at a diner or something
he does something I don't think he needs
see I think he's now just observing how
this universe will play out the events
that he witnessed in another universe so
I think he is TV version of the TV
version of dr. Manhattan that we're
going to see is he is just a casual
observer of what is happening he is not
making any specific actions or reactions
and I think Ozymandias is going to try
to take advantage of him in some way but
I don't think he's an actual threat
throughout this entire show I think he's
a watcher just a watcher that's it I
think that's all that's going to happen
say dogs will be here and I promise it
will be HBO's got the budget for larger
than ever but I don't think he's going
to be an actual threat in this show I
think Ozzy Mantis is the real threat and
I think dr. Manhattan is like a false
lead gotcha so so he basically dudes on
vacation he's too expensive it's a
pretty pretty road to it
I got a 4-1 ask me my idea I don't know
if we have time Marina what's dr.
Manhattan okay so you think dr.
Manhattan isn't a threat but I think
he's a triple threat Sharon's play and
books the lead he's a dancer he's a
singer he's an actor and he goes on to
have a fabulous career on an
off-broadway stage performers guys I I
enjoyed all of these I don't think that
we're gonna be very right at all but but
we'll see Jeremy Irons I hope they
circle on them that on the show that
weird voice he's doing guys it's almost
wrapped up I do see that Eric's actually
in the lead how is that 4.25 but good
work there is just as we wrap up here
there is one last way things can change
and I just a reminder that the winner
with most points at the end gets their
wish to come true and I have your wishes
here but this is our final chance for
points and these are road questions yeah
all right guys it's Halloween next week
yes pitch me what's the best nerd
costume you can have this year dr.
manaan oh my dudes a children's holiday
I stand by my choice if you really want
to scare the kids do Iron Man after his
face got melted off we snap disfigure oh
yes I put it out there if you want to do
real scary that's how you do a Halloween
just like I mean you have to write it's
the most recent version of Iron Man Man
yeah
I would do cap and Peggy dancing with
each other so like I did to say it's
like a message it's a hit message like
I'm both of these things I wouldn't
either
err continue with your label a quarter
guys wrote question director Pedro
almodóvar said this week that Marvel
movies lack sexuality what's the sexiest
of the Marvel movies though this is easy
no problem sorry you see man and just
because it has poverty it has Paul Rudd
but it also has Evangeline Lilly yes
Michael Douglas a Michelle Pfeiffer
together man and possibly kissing I
don't know if they're allowed to kiss
some Marvel movies I think they are
pretty sure and you get um well those
are all Union I think Michael Douglas
and Michelle Pfeiffer are all the sexual
energy you need him oh yeah I mean
ragnaroks pretty sick we were a frame
away from Hulk dick in that movie a
frame away from home yeah I went frame
by frame I'm gonna say all the early
Iron Man's cuz he's just a he's just an
F machine he just goes through with
ladies at leisure and pleasure I don't
have enough blocks to keep give them up
wait no I do okay you get one you go one
and then can you give that one to Eric
down at the end we also throw out there
that the correct answer about that last
one was definitely Scarlett Johansson is
just tickling and foreplay and last road
question oh and it works out nicely I do
have one blast longer valid
sebastian stan who plays the winter
soldier said in an interview that his
new Wakanda made arm it gonna have some
new tricks what's the least expected new
trick that arm could have spending a
basketball harlem globetrotter style I
got the Globetrotters are suing us we
don't have the marina's that'd be great
but and then Eric's everything everyone
says for the rest episode we must sing
it to the melody of the Star Wars theme
[Applause]
we got some great videos to come to the
channel about what's really in the vault
that ray and Kyle are in in the trailer
follow us on Twitter all of us on
Twitter
rogue theory hashtag what yeah go am I
allowed to plug some thing or I follow
me as Sam basher on Twitter as a podcast
so you could listen to this nonsense
and follow us on Twitter at new rock
stars follow me at 4 million on
Instagram and Twitter thank you guys so
much
[Music]